There is a play
by one of my favorite writers,
Nobel laureate Wole Soyinka,
I would like to tell you about,
"The Swamp Dwellers."
"The Swamp Dwellers"
are about a blind beggar
who attempts to buy a piece of swampland
because he believes
that the swamps will provide him
with a better livelihood.
However, the villagers
in that swamp believe
that deep in the forests
of the swamp lies a deity
whose job is to protect them
from all misfortune.
There is another swamp
that protects us from misfortune.
And holds the promise
of humanity's survival.
Those are the peatlands
of the Congo Basin.
The peatlands of the Congo Basin
are a lush, vast, expanse of weeds, shrubs
and trees that absorb carbon
from the atmosphere.
They span 145,000 kilometers.
The peat formations
began 10,000 years ago,
when man moved from
hunter-gatherer to farmer.
Nature, I guess, figured,
"I better start protecting myself."
A couple of years ago,
scientists discovered
that these tropical peatlands
are probably the largest
carbon sink in the world.
They store 30 billion tons of carbon.
If they did not exist,
we would have probably
already stepped beyond
the threshold of 1.5 degrees of warming.
However, the peatlands are under threat.
We have, of course,
oil explorations being contemplated.
Logging licenses
have already been awarded.
And many of the communities
that live around the peatlands
have just this for survival.
We have all collectively seen,
in the Amazon forest,
burning down because of economic interest.
Turning this forest
from carbon sink to carbon source.
We have witnessed, in Indonesia,
the swamps drained
for palm oil plantations.
Turning them from carbon sink
to carbon source.
It will be devastating if the same fate
were to befall the peatlands
of the Congo Basin.
The peatlands are a passion of mine.
I believe they must be protected.
But we must also, in this fight
against climate change,
ensure that responsibility
and accountability
are adequately apportioned.
The world emits over
54 billion tons of carbon.
The peatlands of the Congo Basin
absorb a large majority of that.
Africa emits 1.2 billion
tons of carbon a year.
And the communities
that live around the peatlands
have no access to basic services.
Education, health care,
clean drinking water, an adequate meal,
good transportation, technology.
Clearly, they are not tweeting.
The peatlands are an economic asset,
which, if valued appropriately,
could provide the stepping stone
for these communities
to improve their livelihoods.
Nature has acted already
as a store of value for the peatlands.
A kind of federal reserve.
Now, imagine if we had a price
for carbon at 50 dollars.
With 30 billion tons of carbon
sequestered in the peatlands,
we're talking at 1.5 trillion.
A peatland development fund
could help us today
to address the stubborn
and seemingly persistent
developmental challenges
that the continent faces today.
This is not just about decarbonization.
This is also about
development with dignity.
This is about equity.
It is about justice,
and it is about transparency.
(Applause)
Indeed, Africa has not
contributed enormously
to the climate crisis.
But we have visibly contributed enormously
to keeping the planet alive.
We can, therefore ...
(Applause)
Not expect, but as the blind beggar,
we continue to plead for assistance
to achieve a better livelihood,
and we certainly cannot be like
Wole Soyinka’s swamp dwellers
who wait patiently
while the world overlooks
and undermines Africa's contribution
to climate change.
Science has recognized
Africa's contribution.
I ask you to join me
in recognizing Africa's contribution,
and collectively,
we must ask the markets to recognize
and adequately reward
Africa's contribution
by putting a price on carbon.
(Applause)